bonjour ravi de retrouver sur lcp public
sénat seller d'europe hebdo nous sommes
comme toujours au coeur du parlement
européen à bruxelles cette semaine zoom
sur le problème des minorités nationales
au sein même de l'union européenne on ne
le sait pas forcément mais la lettonie
accueille une importante minorité russe
des russophones qui menacent de faire
sécession et estiment que leurs droits
sont bafoués
mais d'abord c'est la tradition la
question d'actualité la commission
européenne va-t-elle demander à la
france de revoir son budget explications
en quelques secondes on se retrouve
juste après avec le point de vue d'une
députée allemande
la france monsieur le premier ministre
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur sous peine
de se voir mis sous tutelle par la
commission européenne
la france deuxième économie européenne
un déficit qui dérape et une dette de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros l'équivalent
ou presque de son produit intérieur brut
face à ce nouveau dérapage français
bruxelles pourrait sévir à la clé une
amende fixée à 0,2 pour cent de la
richesse nationale soit plus de 4
milliards d'euros paris n'a pas respecté
ses engagements mais pour certains c'est
l'europe qui est responsable de la
politique de bruxelles et madame merkel
est une politique qui plonge le
continent dans la récession
cette politique pourtant par il a
accepté 9 décembre 2011 sommet européen
de bruxelles la france signent un pacte
avec ses partenaires chaque état de la
zone euro envers a désormais son budget
à la commission européenne avant le vote
au parlement
objectif éviter la répétition du
scénario de 2008 lorsque la grèce avait
menti sur ses comptes plongeant le
continent dans la crise des ornais la
commission européenne pourra sanctionner
financièrement les mauvais élèves pour
bruxelles la france continue de dépenser
beaucoup plus qu'elle ne gagne
conséquence le déficit français pourrait
atteindre 4,3 pour cent du pib en 2015
loin des 3% fixée par le pacte de
stabilité
la france mouton noir de l'europe
va-t-elle être sanctionné par la
commission européenne on en parle avec
une députée album bonjour ingeborg grâce
le vous êtes membres du pp le groupe qui
rassemble les partis de droite chrétien
démocrate et du centre en europe dont là
de céder ou s'est soudain cayla merkel
alors vous êtes aussi membre de la très
sérieuse commission du budget et du
contrôle budgétaire
ça rigole pas dit nous en toute
franchise ce que vous pensez de ce
budget français est ce que paris mérite
d'être sanctionné paris mérite d'être
sanctionné c'est clair parce que c'est
paris n'a pas obtenu ces engagements ça
c'est clair parce que clairement ça
c'est clair paris n'a pas tenu ce qu'on
a promis pour le budget 2014 c'était
quoi ses promesses cette promesse était
de revenir dans le budget en déficit de
3% c'était ça la promesse il ya deux ans
c'est pour ça qu'on a donné encore un
délai de deux ans ces deux ans sont
maintenant passées on voit et on sait ce
que ce qui préoccupe beaucoup les
allemands on voit que tous ces délais
nous a servi pas à grand chose le
gouvernement les gouvernements français
ont beaucoup trop attendu alors il ya eu
des délais accordés aussi à l'allemagne
plusieurs fois par la même commission
européenne vous dites qu aujourd'hui
l'allemagne a fait les efforts et pas la
france l'allemagne a fait des efforts
nous nous tenons ce qu'on a décidé il ya
plusieurs années et là on est tout à
fait dans le plan malgré deux mains
tentative de déranger ce plan là je
crois qu'il faut être un peu sérieux il
faut tenir ses promesses sinon ça sert à
rien je crois que toute la zone euro les
troubles de la zone euro vont revenir
parce que la situation en france la
situation en italie n'aspire pas du tout
la confiance il y va de la confiance est
là les marchés financiers n'ont plus la
confiance en nous c'est ça le problème
et si la commission européenne décidé de
sanctionner paris que ferait alors
l'allemagne et ce qu'elles auraient
intérêt à laisser tomber son partenaire
historique finalement ce qu'elle n'y
perdrait pas quelqu'un que doit-elle
faire la personne me lasser tomber la
france juste au contraire il faut
encourager la france afin de faire ce qu
ce qu'ils ont promis et cela qu'il faut
faire si ça veut dire encouragé avec la
manière forte ou de manière plus
diplomatique
moi je préfère la manière forte parce
que la manière diplomatique n'a servi
c'est très clair nous sommes très déçus
mais nous sommes aussi un peu désespéré
nous avons urgemment besoin de la france
nous avons besoin d'une france forte
hausse et vu toute la situation
extérieure nous avons besoin de la
france est pour ça qu il faut agir mais
il faut aussi faire l'everest réformes
structurelles et c'est ce qui manque
aussi mais là on en parle en france des
réformes structurelles justement on
évoque notamment une éventuelle réforme
du système d'indemnisation du chômage
qui serait très généreux ministre
français le tout nouveau ministre
français de l'économie l'a évoqué
mais le président françois hollande le
président français françois hollande
reste plus vague je vous propose
d'écouter ses déclarations de françois
hollande c'était lors du sommet à milan
pour l'emploi écouter
sur l'indemnisation du chômage il y à
une convention qui vient d'être signée
en 2014 et une autre est prévue en 2016
et il y à une rencontre organisée entre
les partenaires sociaux et
l'organisation qui est chargé justement
de l'accompagnement des chômeurs pour
l'emploi pour que nous puissions
améliorer encore le soutien
l'accompagnement pour aller vers
l'emploi le seul la seule réforme pour
moi qui compte c'est celle qui peut
apporter plus d'emplois
ingeborg grassley ce que le système
français d'assurance chômage et roger
dayraut est ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin je crois que les ventes je crois
que le gouvernement français sait très
bien ce qu'il faut faire il ya tant
d'études là dessus mais il manque les
décisions après je crois que la france
est très bien ce qu'il faut faire et ce
n'est pas à une mesure près de l'émotion
une bonne mesure d'aller de conduire une
réforme plus profonde de ce système là
si nous on regarde on regarde les toiles
et les benchmarks internationaux
c'est clair que la france a chuté au
niveau des taxes à neuf points
maintenant vous êtes parmi des pays
africains et là il faut faire quelque
chose dans les taxis faut faire quelque
chose dans le système chômage il faut
inciter il faut encourager à prendre du
travail il faut il faut fallait
faciliter aussi pour les entreprises
d'embaucher des gens et bien sûr aussi
de les licencier si le travail il ya
cette réalité des marchés il ya aussi la
réalité sociale terrible de certaines
personnes qui restent au chômage pendant
des mois qu'ils ne trouvent pas d'emploi
malgré les recherches est ce que vous
trouvez pas que c'est un peu les
stigmatiser aussi que cette politique a
aussi un coût social important bien sûr
je ne vois pas pourquoi c'est une
stigmatisation si je fais tout pour que
justement ces personnes là peuvent avoir
du travail c'est un problème systémique
et je crois que la france va s'y
attaquer et la france est très bien le
gouvernement sait très bien ce qu'il
faut faire mais n'ont pas le courage il
faut aussi améliorer le dialogue social
je suis toujours frappé par le temps
dure entre les patrons et les syndicats
et là je crois que le gouvernement a un
vrai rôle à jouer alors quand de votre
pays l'allemagne le nouveau chef de
l'eurogroupe le néerlandais dice bloom a
dit qu a mis en garde l'allemagne en
l'incitant à faire davantage de réformes
en disant qu'elle ne doit pas dormir se
reposer sur ses lauriers est ce que vous
êtes vous à prouver ce qu'il dit est ce
que l'allemagne pourrait elle aussi
mener d'autres réformes à 100%
j'approuve ce que das glow m'a dit et
nous on sait très bien verte où il faut
aller il faut avant tout il faut avant
tout plus de l'ust investissements
privés nous sommes une société
vieillissante et notre problème c'est
que les gens ont beaucoup d'epargne qui
dorment sur leurs comptes et là il faut
les mettre dans les combats assez
d'investissements on a line up mais les
investissements privés s'il vous plaît
pas les investissements de l'état ce
qu'on confond ce en france on entend
toujours investissements de l'état nous
on croit pas tellement en l'état s'il
vous plaît il nous faut inciter le
marché le marché privé et c'est là la
solution c'est là la solution aussi pour
lutter effectivement contre le chauffeur
en attendant il est le gouvernement
allemand a confirmé que la croissance
serait revue à la baisse
elle sera moins importante que prévu en
allemagne qu'est-ce que ça c'est pas le
bon moment peut-être pour l'allemagne
pour pour changer de politique
économique pour qu'elle ne soit plus
uniquement tourné sur le cap unique de
la rigueur parler un peu de croissance
et d'investissement justement c'est pas
le bon moment il faut pas confondre les
critiques nous on pense à
l'investissement privé comment inciter
l'investissement privé et par
l'investissement de l'état nous on croit
pas ce qu'on a vu pendant les dernières
années comme ça on a on s'est entêté
temps c'est que l'état a fait des
programmes conjoncturels qui n'ont rien
apporté sauf de nouveaux tête qui
maintenant nous prennent la possibilité
d'agir je crois qu'il faut tout faire
pour des mauvais pour mobiliser ces
fonds privés pour des investissements en
privé et là le gouvernement y travaille
et on doit faire quelque chose parce que
ça ne va pas comme une société
vieillissante ne pense qu'a légué
léguer sa fortune c'est la meilleure
fortune c'est les investissements dans
le privé et vous pensez pas que dans
l'immédiat l'allemagne aurait intérêt à
assouplir un peu sa position
notamment sur la rigueur budgétaire
alors même qu'elle souffre par exemple
directement de de moindres importations
de venus de russie en raison de la crise
du crédit ne serait pas le bon moment
pour infléchir un peu la fameuse
politique allemande c'est à dire pour
faire plus de dette ça ça nous on veut
pas on veut parler de sujet tabou en
allemagne la dette celle le sujet tabou
parce qu'on en attend et on se demande
qui va payer pour tout ça et c'est pour
ça que si on voit la stabilité de la
zone euro cette stabilité dépend de
notre capacité de repayer nos têtes
l'agenais de fortes doute quant à dette
à la dette allemande quant à la dette
française quant à la dette italienne y
compris les marchés financiers on se
doute aussi un jour il faut payer nos
dettes la de la dette allemande est
importante on a parlé de celle de la
france mais l'allemagne bat aussi
d'aider des records impressionnant
qu'est ce qu'elle fait de plus que nous
avec une dette aussi énorme que nous
cette dette la salle elle n'est pas
venue en une journée elle ne partira pas
en une journée ça nous on va on a fait
un plan qui dit qu'à partir de 2015 il y
aura plus budget il ya le budget à
endettement zéro le budget annuel
c'est-à-dire un troll fait dévisser
c'est déjà un pas en avant après il faut
repayer il faut penser à repayer et
c'est ce que fait l'allemagne ça va
durer 20 ans 25 ans mais enfin on s'y
est mis et c'est ce qui manque encore en
france vous dites que la france vit
continue à vivre au-dessus de ses moyens
finalement ce qui gène peut être
bruxelles aussi l'allemagne c'est
qu'elles dépensent beaucoup plus
qu'elles ne gagnent ccsa au fond la
vraie critique que vous auriez affaire
la france la vraie critique c'est que la
france prend beaucoup trop de temps fait
ne fait que des annonces et ne fais
jamais des décisions parlement pour
implémenter ces annonces et elle n'aime
pas qu'on me les mettre en oeuvre et
après elle n'est pas suffisamment
conséquent parce que bien sûr il ya des
protestations mais après il faut il faut
tenir la route et là je crois qu'on doit
tous tenir ensemble il va pas de blâmer
la france mais il y va de la légalité
n'a pas à y gagner voilà il y va de
soutenir les dirigeants français dans ce
cheminement et de faire clair à tout le
monde qu'on a les mêmes intérêts nous
avons un intérêt très fort que la france
reprenne des forces économiques et quand
je suis en france j'ai fait des études à
paris je suis très préoccupé quand je
vois paris aujourd'hui qu'en pareille à
20 ans je suis très préoccupée alors en
tout cas la discussion budgétaire il
lancé à l'assemblée nationale paris a
transmis son budget à la commission
européenne on verra bien ce qu'il va en
ressortir merci beaucoup il le board
regrette d'avoir été avec nous on
poursuit cette émission direction riga
en lettonie vous ne le savez peut-être
pas mais ce petit pays balte de 2,2
millions d'habitants compte une
importante minorité russe dont une
partie estime que ses droits sont
bafoués et menace même de faire
sécession regardez ce reportage signé
françois à goulens et khaled mahmoud
des dom scintillant au monument
soviétique des vieille lada aux trains
arrêtés en gare à chaque coin de rue la
russie hantent la lettonie ici près de
riga même les hélicoptères rouillé de
l'armée rouge certes la décorer les
jardins
les chaînes de télévision du grand
voisin envahissent les ondes sur les
écrans le visage de celui qui agite le
pays depuis des mois le président
vladimir poutine fait son 62e
si
la grande russie c'est aussi le rêve
d'un autre vladimir linderman ce
nationaliste d'origine russe milite pour
l'indépendance de la lacc galy une
région layton peuplées de russes juste à
côté de la frontière cet activiste
risque la prison pour ses idées tout
comme les militants de son mouvement
politique partis se battre en ukraine
avec les séparatistes pro
l'ukraine ou la crimée ce ne sont pas
des pays étrangers pour nous c'est notre
peuple qui habite là-bas la situation en
ukraine est très semblable à celle d'ici
nous subissons nous les russes une
opération de les tony's à sion et 2d
russification
des idées qui font mouche les récentes
élections générales ont fait la part
belle aux convictions communautaire le
parti des russophones allié du parti de
vladimir poutine demeure la première
force politique au parlement le discours
nationaliste et souvent entendus dans
les quartier russe de riga mais les
russophones sont loin d'être tous du
même avis
d'un côté une bonne partie des jeunes
russophone se considère comme européens
même s'ils ont comme langue maternelle
russe même si une partie d'entre eux ont
voté pour le parti russophone de
lettonie gursky à calais de l'autre les
personnes âgées ont une nostalgie de
l'union soviétique et surtout des
garanties sociales et du mode de vie
qu'ils avaient à l'époque mais en late
game il y a aussi des russes attachés à
l'état
corrado crise n'est pas très beau
la laddh games à seulement 200 km de la
capitale est déjà si proche de
l'encombrant voisin ici on parle on
mange on respire russes et les noms des
villages emporte la couleur
là où gaffe pils la deuxième ville du
pays ne compte que 20 % de laiton c'est
dans cette enclave russe au milieu des
lacs et des forêts qu'alexandre lazio
n'offrent a décidé d'installer son
affaire
ici c'est un sauna de type russe on peut
aussi se baigner dans le lac et au fond
on va étendre le centre jusqu'à la
colline là bas ce jeune investisseur pro
européen fraîchement débarqué de la
capitale construit des chambres d'hôtes
qui attire des visiteurs étrangers le
jeune homme est d'origine russe mais
s'est fait naturaliser les tons ya deux
autres la dîmière poutine dit qu'il veut
nous protéger nous les russes de
lettonie mais nous protéger de quoi
c'est plutôt de lui qu'on devrait avoir
peur ici nous sommes à côté de la
frontière et mes amis de riga se moque
de moi ils disent que nous serons les
premiers à saluer les chars russes
moi je suis né ici en lettonie et je me
sens plus européen que rue
dans ce mélange identitaire certains ne
savent même plus qui ils sont c'est le
cas des trois son île russe de lettonie
qui sont apatrides ya gagné grotte bon
je m'appelle yevgeny drawbaugh tu es je
suis un nom citoyens lettons
l'état letton n'a jamais régulariser la
situation de ces oubliés ils
représentent 10% de la population du
pays et ont été envoyés ici par l'urss
yves bény drogba se bat pour être
reconnus comme citoyens lettons mais en
tant qu'ancien membre du parti
communiste il n'a pas le droit de passer
le test de naturalisation nous n'avons
pas le droit de voter nous les non
citoyens nous sommes exclus de la vie
politique nous ne pouvons pas non plus
être élus devenir fonctionnaire ou
posséder un bien immobilier
lors de l'indépendance en 1991 on nous
avait promis que toutes les personnes
habitant sur le territoire de lettonie
recevrait la citoyenneté layton en
réalité le peuple a été trompé
ces inégalités dans une région très
pauvre menacent de radicaliser la
communauté russe de lettonie l'union
européenne sommes depuis des années le
gouvernement de régler cette situation
quant à la russie l'argument des
minorités opprimées et du pain béni pour
s'attirer les sympathies des derniers
russ modèle
voilà pour ce reportage de françois
gaulin quelle est la réalité on va
entendre nos deux invités d'abord sandra
kalniete -bonjour députée européenne
layton vous avez une histoire terrible
vous êtes né sur ce qui était le
territoire soviétique au goulag vous
êtes né au goulag l'occupation
soviétique les pays baltes ou la lessive
vécu dans votre chair à on imagine que
vous avez beaucoup de réactions après le
visionnage de ce reportage avec vous
alain cadec député
député français vous est notamment
membre de la délégation pour les
relations entre l'union européenne et la
russie on vous entendra d'abord une
question avoue sandra quand il y était
en tant que layton quand vous voyez ces
témoignages notamment ses ces citoyens
qui se disent apatrides est-ce que ça
correspond à la à la réalité qui est
calé pourquoi se retrouve-t-il comme ça
première chose que je voudrais dire tout
de suite que depuis que j'ai
notre pays à découvrir indépendance
j'essaie vraiment fatigué a expliqué à
tout le monde ce qui est évident au dire
parce que c'est important en même temps
ces témoignages mais il ya vingt cinq
ans les quatre noeuds 80 de 2015 on va
vite et 20 50 depuis qu'elle est ni à
restaurer son indépendance est ce que
vous pouvez imaginer qu'un pays
dans lesquels la législation ne
correspond pas au
niveau européen aux valeurs européen
pourrait être accepté comme membre de
l'union européenne et l'otan jamais ce
sont des critères qui sont jugés à la
lettre quand vous y entrer et c'est
pourquoi je suis tellement
fatigué de tous ces reportages qui sont
assez superflu superficiel et peut quoi
je dois toujours justifié ce qui n'est
pas vrai ce qui n'est pas vrai c'est à
dire que quand ils disent c'est cet
homme là nostalgiques de l'union
soviétique il n'a pas là qui n'a pas le
droit de vote est ce que c'est vrai ou
est-ce que c'est faux
il doit ces naturalisés c'est un
procédure assez simple qui était établie
par avec collaboration avec le conseil
européen ça veut dire qu'il ne l'a pas
fait il n'a pas fait cet absolu roues et
je comprends aussi la population âgée
parce qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs
qui fait cette hésitation les premières
beaucoup de on des familles et des amis
en russie elle réussit rapplique un
standard double boucle c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas qu'ils sont citoyens de l'union
européenne
ils doivent payer un visa d'entrée ceux
qui sont résidents comme lui ils peuvent
aller avec les procédures très
simplifiées alors pour répondre à votre
collègue vous êtes député français mais
vous avez beaucoup de relations avec
paul et on met breton vous êtes breton
reste en plus en tout cas vous avez
votre avis aussi sur sur cette question
des minorités nationales qui est une
banque européenne centrale précisément
s'agissant de la lettonie c'est la
lettonie est un état souverain
en plus qui appartient à l'union
européenne dont qui respectent la charte
des droits fondamentaux
c'est ce dont faisait allusion à une
qualité tout de suite et à partir de là
on fait confiance évidemment à la
lettonie pour faire
respecter la démocratie dans son pays et
intégrer ces populations risquent bien
sûr pour l'héritage déjà sur la mesure
tout à fait et elle le fait ah bah
écoutez
si je constate le reportage je suis pas
tout à fait convaincu si j'écoute sandra
cagnes et et j'en suis un peu plus
puisque elle me dit que c'est le cas
peut-être que certains
citoyens d'origine russe ne souhaite pas
être naturalisé c'est possible ne font
pas tout pour le devenir c'est
regrettable mais en tous les cas encore
une fois la lettonie est un état
souverain
adhérents de l'union européenne et qui
respecte la charte des droits
fondamentaux en tous les cas je le pense
est ce que cela veut dire que moscou est
donc la dîmière comptines attise la peur
la crainte instrumentalise c'est cette
population russophone bon lettonie je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est en semaines alizé pas seulement
en lettonie met ainsi dans d autres pays
européens aux sondés
communauté russophone assez important
parce que sans vision du monde lui ce
qu'il veut créer
le fait de ces populations en salt ii
des agents dans des pays étrangères pour
cette monde russes mais je voudrais
revenir à l'intégration quand vous
pourrez voir l'intégration c'est un
processus extrêmement compliqué pas
seulement en lettonie mais radio partout
en europe et la france y compris en
savent quelque chose sur sa sueur et les
fait que nous avec cet héritage
soviétique pendant toutes ces années
nous avons su créer une société qui a
trouvé un sorte de cohabitation un
modèle d'intégration
avec deuxième étape est quelque chose
qui pourrait servir pas seulement un
autre pays mais aussi à l'europe au
programme comment intégrer des
populations étrangères alors vous dites
ce qui se passe en lettonie c'est voilà
c'est pas forcément le reflet de la
réalité la question centrale c'est celle
aussi de la russie finalement et quelle
politique l'europe doit-elle avoir à
l'égard de la russie jusqu'où va aller
la fluence
l'influencent russe je vous propose
d'écouter cette réaction du ministre
letton des affaires étrangères écouter
échoué d'entrée à
l'europe ne réagit pas assez fort face à
la russie
aux russes nous pensons que les bases
instinct vont devenir de plus en plus
fort
nous craignons que l'histoire ne se
répète et que nous soyons les témoins
d'autres drames il se peut alors que
nous voyons plus de conflits plus de
contestation en moldavie en géorgie et
dans les autres pays qui entourent la
fédération de russie
alain cadec vous vous parlez à la russie
en tout cas dans le cadre de votre
délégation l'europe ne parle pas comment
l'europe par la démondialisation mais
c'est vrai que moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent que l'europe doit d'abord être
ferme avec escales à la russie mais elle
doit aussi dialoguer avec la russie
c'est pas aujourd'hui on parle pas il ya
un embargo on parle pas avec la russie
on fait tout pour ne pas parler avec la
russie je pense que c'est pas la bonne
solution alors il faut avoir un discours
de fermeté par rapport au respect des
droits de l'homme par rapport au respect
des peuples par rapport au respect des
frontières des pays mais il faut aussi
dialoguer avec la maman je rappelle il
faut avoir ces deux il faut avoir ces
deux rappelons rappelons-nous le la
géorgie qu'est ce qu'elle fait le
président nicolas sarkozy il a dialogué
avec vladimir poutine et il a en même
temps taper du poing sur la table il a
fait les deux et qui s'équilibrent grâce
à ça il a réglé les problèmes de la
géorgie pour régler la pression qu
l'union européenne doit aujourd'hui
s'ouvrira la russie aussi parlé avec la
russie ait changé avec la russie c'est
pas en faisant des blocages qu'on y
arrivera à mon avis et en dialoguant ce
en échangeant comme ça c'est d'accord
avec ce que dit alain cadec il faudra
c'est tout à fait d'accord avec le cfa
du coup il faut dialoguer avec la russie
non je ne suis pas d'accord avec mon
partenaire de cette émission qu on ne
dialogue pas parce que l'europe a fait
tellement de ces forts
président hollande
peut la chancelière angela merkel angela
merkel elle parle trois fois par semaine
fait peut-être par les trois fois par
semaine au gré des rolex et c'est dans
le très beau tir mais
pour avoir un dialogue qu'il faut avoir
au moins un
mois je rappelle encore le l'épisode
sarkozy et la géorgie nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque avait dialogué avec vladimir
poutine mais avait aussi montrer sa
fermeté avait tapé sur la table il a
réussi à régler en france on va fêter
son 75e anniversaire du débarquement oui
et invitait aussi président poutine
c'étaient les premières encore le cas
dans le prix du lait oui après la
dégustation de la crinière que lui était
invité dans sept lieux et et parmi les
autres leaders et cette première
rencontre avec président porochenko qui
aura lieu
pendant cette célébration tu te fais
c'est très important vous oubliez aussi
que c'est les dialogues théâtre plus tôt
à minsk qui enfin amener ailleurs
dit en français découvrent ce
décès de feu parce que ce sont des
efforts diplomatiques ont été déployés
par l'union européenne merci ce sera le
mot de la fin il faut en tout cas
méditer les leçons de l'histoire vous
nous parliez du débarquement merci
beaucoup pour ce témoignage merci alain
cadec j'avais beaucoup d'avoir été là
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même lieu
même heure avec nora a m'a dit merci à
tous de votre fidélité cha cha
ouais